so
i'll start from this page the page that
has been shared with you and many of you
might have visited this page so this is
the page that describes the
high school summer training program in
uh much more detail and you'll find a
lot of resources here a lot of
information that will help you
understand more about the design and
more about the curriculum more about the
topics and more about the schedule of
the
programs upcoming
sessions on all of that so let's let's
begin uh with the with an overview as
you've already learned that what are the
major topics and how we are going to do
this and uh if
during this
presentation
if you have any question please feel
free to
uh let me know uh by putting it in the
chat or on muting yourself so
as we are having the first webinar here
and we are discussing about the program
we are going to offer three different
types of training which will be
available for all of you interested to
participate in so these three type of
trainings will include uh different
types of topics different types of
outcome so let me explain that like very
briefly uh so we have uh listed out some
of the advantages and how this uh
training was is going to be uh including
what all topics and how the system works
you you
already created a login online so that
will help you uh to
orient yourself and get comfortable with
the resources that we'll be sharing so
you have an option uh as i was saying i
was saying that uh we are going to uh
we are going to uh invite uh students to
join these programs which are available
so how do we learn about what what will
be the topics will be what and how which
dates they will be
covered and whatever what will be the
resources which will be uh you know put
together for those sessions so let's
take a look at by clicking these
specific programs so we have listed out
here like four programs from learning
about genomics and working with an
expert to do some genomic research
utilizing different resources then to
learn about biomedical data science
using coding
by applying r and python and then to be
able to do your own research by
participating in an independent research
project so from understanding very
beginner level uh beginner level
courses by understanding and going
through the mentor and the support team
you'll be able to develop that uh
understanding of how to utilize big data
and how to utilize these different
applications that you heard of so i
think in this meeting and during the
call we
you might have heard many terms which
were new to you um
if that is true please let me know if
say put yes in the chat box so
for you to learn about those new
keywords and new terminologies we have
prepared a lot of uh resources that will
definitely going to help you go through
them strategically so let me let's first
go through the first program uh so you
know genomics in the virtual lab very
special program where we have a
excellent mentor
who will take you professor sona
vasudevan from georgetown university a
very prestigious university in the us
and along with our mentors which which
we will start from 18th july and uh it
will be available for you to enroll for
uh
one and a half months that is 45 days uh
training or a 60 day training or a 90
day training based on your availability
and the time that you can allocate for
such training so um that's the timeline
for the program to start you will also
find like a
overview and you can see that how the
previous year student presented and we
will be going through some of these uh
outcomes of the program because it's
important to understand that what
happens after the program what are the
things that we're gonna learn and if
there is some projects that we're going
to work on so
we will be talking about that but before
that let me take you through the
schedule first and a little bit about
how do you join the program so uh 18th
of july we have the first session which
is introduction to bioinformatics very
basic uh which involves understanding of
formix technologies role of big data in
biomedicines and then
different repositories resources and
tools how to access the
learn omics logic and its projects and
courses how to access the topper
bioinformatics research platform and uh
start you know using some of the
pipelines so it's very exciting but yeah
we will start with a very basic overview
of how that
all of this is going to work for you so
that is the first session which is
scheduled for
july 18th which will be
a live session then we have these
different sessions uh which will be
asynchronously available which means
that you will be getting the recording
and you will be getting all the
resources and whatever you need for to
learn the topics that are going to cover
uh on july 22nd uh and an opportunity
always to talk
understand some of the concepts some of
the topics some of the problems that you
face so there will be a team supporting
all of this then we have the next
section which is more about
understanding how uh we can do
comparative sequence analysis how can we
correlate it with the with the
evolutionary analysis so we will learn
about sequences from sequences we will
understand how sequences fold into
three-dimensional structure and how do
we analyze the structure from sequence
how do we analyze those uh
three-dimensionally model structure in
in our laptops in our systems and
understand about different types of uh
mutations maybe that causes the
important uh or uh changes in the body
right so we will be learning about all
of those from sequence to structure and
then to function and to understand
function we will take some of the case
studies and we will review um some of
the diseases types that we have
described and discussed in this webinar
previously so i'll not go into the
detail but
one of the activity that is planned and
which will be one of the uh i mean
landmarks or highlights of this program
is that you will have an opportunity
after the first five session to work on
a small project and showcase it's like a
more of a review to find out some of the
insights from what you have learned and
apply to some of the projects that we we
are
letting you know or you can uh also give
your own proposal so this weekend
activity will include preparing a couple
of slides and sharing with us and
discussing if you can work on this
project if this project is feasible or
if this research is feasible so that
would be
about you know finding a research
question followed by that there will be
specialized sessions which will cover
very important topics uh for for
research and very important topics for
you know learning which is to how do you
do literature review and how do you
design a project and then how what are
the different elements that will be
designed inside the project so on august
8 we have that session where we will be
sharing you how to design a
bioinformatics research project how to
do literature review and all of that and
then we will dive into some sort of
specializations which is like virology
here the virology uh you all have
written as the covet
pandemic and we will be learning about
different aspects of virology and how
bioinformatics is applied in biology and
it will involve uh
involve
understanding of how do you apply some
basic r uh programming by understanding
uh and utilizing some sequences and then
playing it in the code playground and
then doing it in the code playground as
you have seen so followed by that we
have some sessions on microbial
communities where we will learn about
metagenomics because it's very important
now to correlate between these different
uh
technologies and the data that they
produce so it actually helps us in you
know developing a very good research
project so all of these sessions are
kind of designed to help you
develop that understanding the ideas
that ideas will automatically
automatically come when you when you
understand that how they are applied in
different case case studies and how they
are applied in terms of you know doing
it uh by doing it yourself on uh tbi
info platform uh using the hands-on
analysis and then we have some case
studies uh which involves you know
vaccine antibody and antiviral drugs and
analysis of genome or ncbi viruses where
we will be exploring the public
repositories because a lot of data and
huge huge amount of data are being
deposited every day and i and we all
think that there is an opportunity to
investigate further into those data sets
big data sets which is usually very
difficult to do but otherwise it will be
much easier through the program and
through the resources that will be
sharing and that's an opportunity for
all of you to take now uh after this
first uh the second half of the
program where you will understand and go
through all of these public repositories
tools to use and uh
technologies to apply you will have an
opportunity to
do a project presentation where you come
up with your own idea and we will be uh
there will be judges uh from academia
and industry and we have an amazing
panel of judges uh from uh
who are from top universities leaders in
their field uh can give you really good
feedback about how the project is
shaping up so that's how the program is
planned and after 26th of august till
the end of your
program we you will have an opportunity
to discuss with the mentors and the team
and work on your research project and
research proposal and uh if you have a
good research project proposal then
there's an opportunity for you to join
the research fellowship and work on an
independent research project that i'll
come next but before that uh let me take
you to the registration process so if
you have already created
your uh login here
what all you have to do is just uh you
know go to this page and then go to this
section where you can choose a
subscription click the subscription
button where you want to choose the
subscription and then go through these
simple steps and complete your
registration if you're from a
low income country group then you are uh
eligible for scholarship and you will be
able
all you have to do is that write
an email to us
suggesting the same
and we will be able to guide you with
the scholarship process now going back
to the second program we have these
different opportunities that we have we
have been discussing so please feel free
to ask any questions related to the
program that we are discussing the next
program is focused more on your data
science more on doing coding more on
learning how to apply data science
techniques into
using biomedical or biological data so
maybe some of you are more interested in
data science some of you are more
interested in investigating or doing
biological research so
uh it is based on your uh
interest you can join and choose between
these programs so now the next program
that i wanted to show you is the data
science program which is going to start
very soon on 4th july where we will be
going through the basics of programming
for everyone to get you know um
get to know about uh the
get on get on the same page perhaps
because we have students coming from
different backgrounds and many of uh
many of those students do not have a
background of programming at all so we
have these very beginner level sessions
to help students learn from the uh the
mentors about these uh how to get
started and then installing and going
through the very basics like vectors
matrices libraries and then start
utilizing once you start utilizing you
start working with sequences you learn
about you know how to process data and
we start visualizing an r and then you
go into different type of advanced
visualization and you learn about
machine learning approaches and you
understand that how can you use you know
dimensionality reduction processes or
dimensionality reduction or unsupervised
machine learning processes that can
actually help you to find needle from
the haystack literally from like large
amount of data you'll be able to find
meaningful information using some of
these techniques and then you will be
learning about more statistical and
advanced techniques that will help you
work on a project which is more related
to data analysis application of data
science and uh and machine learning and
all of that so we have detailed session
covering all of these important topics
and then we have a specialization that
you can opt for you can you can either
do both rf python or you can choose one
of these it's up to you but we will have
sessions for both rn and python so first
we will cover r and then we will cover
python so that you can understand
compare and for you know take advantage
of both of these uh
very very powerful
uh programming tools that helps
biologists that helps almost everyone in
today's era of data to gain meaningful
insights and show that in a proper
presentation and get recognition so
that's about the program that we are
going to that we are discussing and uh i
think
uh
we have uh also like uh a different
dates which is to cover that which will
be covered in 45 in one month's time so
you'll have one month time where these
sessions are going to happen bi-weekly
and then uh you will have an opportunity
to discuss with the mentors and learn
about different sections and you all
will also have the asynchronous
coursework uh associated with each of
these sessions so
those coursework are available on
learnomicslogic and you will be able to
get hold of that once you register and
also
once you
start the program so i'll just log out
and i'll just check because i'm already
a part of this program and
it's it's not showing me the
registration part so i'll just show you
the
registration part
so as you can see
the asynchronous material is also
included here you can click on these
links and go to the asynchronous
material and check
what all we will be covering in the
session along with that we have recorded
videos that we will be sharing with you
so that you can do it on your own if you
don't get time and we will also have
flexibility in terms of
in terms of scheduling meetings uh if
you're in us we will have a u.s team
supporting this and have a time
convenient uh for all of us to have the
meeting so similarly you can choose
between the different subscription
levels here and uh also apply for
scholarships if you're from low income
country and have financial problems
now uh just the last part of the
presentation or the discussion
where we are going to discuss once you
have learned all of this once you have
mastered one of these techniques once
you have
practiced on example data sets the next
thing that you would want to do is to do
it on a new problem that is something
that is like a contribution to the
research and the scientific community
because these findings will be new and
uh they are eligible based on their
nobility for publications or for other
uh poster presentations and such
recognition that program is the research
fellowship program and now i like taking
you through this different uh different
types of opportunities so once you have
that like a research project a research
proposal there's an opportunity to
present that and publish that and all of
those uh
uh connect with the research community
using the mixed research symposium which
will be uh which is scheduled to be
happening in august so uh all of this
will make sense uh
to get a really good outcome from this
summer uh if you are
if you're interested if you are
interested in exploring some of these
topics doing some research and using the
skill sets for you for your future so uh
some of these key topics are also
mentioned here and this all has been you
know kind of covered we have excellent
mentors who will be supporting the
program you can watch the video from one
of these basic
training sessions initial sessions for
everyone to be on the same page and then
this research fellowship program or
independent research project is the
highlight because
here you will be able to see that there
are videos from the students who
completed or uh
and completed these uh research
trainings and come up with the wonderful
outcome anytime now it is going to be it
is available since uh june 15th and uh
there's an opportunity to work in a 45
days project 60 days project or a
90 days project the dates are not so
much relevant here because uh you can
join any time and you can start working
on your project so similarly we have the
pricing and you can check out that and
decide which
subscription you would want
and which program that you would want to
enroll to so that's that's the part of
my presentation and i hope all of you
have uh
enjoyed this webinar and
[Music]
you